mientras unos disfrutan del sol en mar
de plata otros sufren los embates de la
ola de calor en buenos aires y sus
alrededores el verano austral ha llegado
acompañado de temperaturas récord y
provocar una saturación del sistema
eléctrico debido al exceso de demanda
hecho que derivó en un apagón de horas
en la capital y la provincia de buenos
aires- edenor informa que alrededor de
las 13 horas ha salido de servicio una
línea de alta tensión debido a un
incendio ocurrido en una vivienda en el
partido de san martín y cuando indique
tal si no me acordé de los pobres chicos
que estaban en la casa con la chica que
los cuida y dije lo voy a encontrar
hechos un charquito de agua así que no
me vine para acá estábamos sin luz en la
casa de barro la situación afectó a unos
700.000 usuarios el gobierno de acuerdo
con medios argentinos como clarín tenía
previsto un plan para evitar cortes en
el suministro durante el verano al
tiempo que estimaba un menor consumo
residencial debido al periodo vacacional
pero éste fue mayor al esperado debido a
las altas temperaturas que de acuerdo
con el servicio de meteorología son
extraordinarias en el país estamos con
temperaturas mínimas por encima de 25 26
grados desde el norte de la patagonia
cuyo la provincia de buenos aires y
también el litoral y con temperaturas de
hasta 43 grados según los pronósticos se
esperan marcas similares en los
termómetros al menos hasta el próximo
domingo la principal empresa de energía
informó que sobre la noche se había
reactivado el servicio en gran parte del
área afectada al tiempo que las
autoridades piden a la población hacer
frente a la ola de calor y tratándose y
evitando la exposición al sol entre las
10 de la mañana y las 5 de la tarde